[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du lundi 11 mai
déconfinement jour 1 cette nouvelle
phase très progressive a débuté
aujourd'hui après deux mois passés à la
maison en raison de la crise sanitaire
du coronavirus hors du masque vivement
recommandée dans l'espace public les
personnes fragiles sont invités aussi à
poursuivre le confinement mais plus
besoin dorénavant de vous munir d'une
attestation pour sortir sauf bien sûr
pour les déplacements de plus de 100 km
comment vivez vous ce premier jour de
déconfinement mathilde et demi et
nicolas landry sont allés poser la
question à quelques 50 livres alors moi
je pas du tout sorti et c'est un petit
peu bizarre je regarde tous là un peu
peur mais après faut sortir mais bon je
suis très optimiste
voilà je suis équipé je suis les
consignes du gouvernement j'ai rendez
vous chez le coiffeur là dans dix
minutes
donc voila c'était la première la
première chose à faire ce matin j'ai pas
peur parce que je me protège
j'essaye de respecter un peu des
consignes quoi voilà je me lave souvent
le mail chez lg les masques quand ya
trop de monde j'ai nommé match quand je
me promène avec dans mon sac là
maintenant profiter un peu avec les
enfants de se promener un peu dans le
nord pas en attendant qu'on le prend
définitivement l'école pour le moment
j'ai les deux jours là j'ai prévu de ne
pas d amener la partie de mes freddy je
vais voir pour probablement je vais
commencer à les amener ce matin certains
ont repris le chemin du bureau même si
le télétravail doit être privilégié par
les employeurs a dit le gouvernement
un peu plus de monde sur les routes et
dans les transports donc avec des
mesures sanitaires mises en place
filtrage des entrées des gares fléchage
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
à saint quentin en yvelines dans les
transports un siège sur de neutraliser
port du masque obligatoire et des
déplacements qui doivent se faire muni
d'une attestation employeur aux heures
de pointe la reprise totale du trafic
n'interviendra pas avant la fin mai pour
ce qui concerne les lignes en service la
ligne rennes et le rer c fonctionne à
50% et pour la ligne u les horaires sont
adaptés et si vous prenez le réseau des
bus sachez que 100% des lignes circulent
à l'exception de celles dédiées au
transport scolaire qui se feront au cas
par cas
il faut monter par l'arrière des
véhicules et la vente des tickets à bord
est interdite en ce lundi 11 mai les
commerces non essentiels à l'exception
des cafés bars et restaurants ont été
autorisés à ouvrir sauf pour les
commerces qui sont situés dans les
grands centres commerciaux vélizy de
parly 2 ou encore l'espace saint quentin
reste par exemple fermer encore
aujourd'hui l'une des reprises
d'activités très attendue par les
français c'est celle des coiffeurs après
deux mois de confinement longueur de
cheveux et épi ont pu à crisper certains
d'entre nous un protocole a été mise en
place pour les nouvelles consignes de
sécurité exemple dans un salon de
coiffure à maurepas avec mathilde et
demi et mélanie poker
de nouveaux gestes sanitaires à adopter
et champeaux obligatoire pour les
clients de nouveaux équipements à porter
pour les professionnels dans ce salon de
maurepas la reprise d'activité était
fortement attendu les quatre coiffes est
arrêté sur le pont dès l'ouverture
donc la désinfection essentiel vraiment
essentiel donc le temps deux des favoris
vote
mais voilà on change de taille pour
cette première heure de reprise la
clientèle est plutôt masculine et le
rasage de près et de rigueur j'en
pouvais plus de makoua déjà un peu long
alors que d'habitude bien les deux
semaines du coup pas dire c'est un peu
important de me sentir comme avant j'ai
ici parce qu'il 13 donc forcément on
trouve pas forcément partout des gens
qui puissent stressé aussi facilement et
et faire les choses proprement
ça devenait vraiment critique se servait
jeu il y avait vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de deux temps qui me laisse en
coiffeur du confinement après deux mois
de confinement ce salon accueille
jusqu'à 40000 euros de perte de chiffre
d'affaires ouvert depuis seulement
octobre 2019 l'établissement a tout de
même pu profiter d'un prêt de l'état
on n'a pas été abandonné il ya quand
même quelques aides
on a réussi à faire un pg donc on s'en
sort très bien et on est aussi que
passer par une plate forme donc pour
faire de la bande de bons d'achat ce qui
nous a permis d'avoir un petit peu de
trésorerie au fur et à mesure pour
pouvoir payer les différentes charges
qui se présentaient dès la première
semaine on a été agréablement surpris on
a eu plus de 1000 euros donc de bons
d'achat donc sur la première semaine aux
mille euros sur un chiffre d'affaires
important peut-être que c'est rien mais
dans sur des situations franchement
c'est vraiment vraiment conséquent le
salon attend jusqu'à une vingtaine de
clients par jour le carnet de
rendez-vous est quasiment complet pour
la semaine est d'ailleurs en ce jour de
déconfinement jour de reprise de
l'activité économique aussi bruno le
maire était dans les yvelines le
ministre de l'économie s'est rendu ce
matin sur un chantier de construction de
logements à saint germain en laye l'éco
quartier qui est située en bord de forêt
pour accompagner les entrepreneurs dans
cette phase qui commence l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines a édité un
guide pratique il recense toutes les
obligations pour les employeurs la mise
en place de mesures de protection
collective et éventuellement individuels
ainsi que la prise en compte d'un
environnement de travail modifié un
guide qui est à télécharger à l'adresse
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
reprise également en progressif pour les
écoles qui rouvrent peu à peu dès cette
semaine dans un premier temps avec les
élèves de grande section et cp cm2 une
rentrée qui se veut souple et
progressive sur la base du volontariat
organisé par les
m ainsi 92 % des écoles de l'académie de
versailles sont dans une démarche de
réouverture une rentrée qui se prépare
depuis la mi avril
écoutez la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles la méta qu'on a utilisées
elle a reposé sans grande surprise sur
trois éléments trois ingrédients la
concertation avec toutes les parties
prenantes d'yvois khademi au niveau
départemental au niveau local la
deuxième chose c'est que vous le savez
le des continents pour ce qui concerne
les écoles repose sur ce cadre tout à
fait indiscutable qui est le respect du
cadre sanitaire c'est la condition
sinequanone de la reprise évidemment on
tient compte des des spécificités de
chacun ce n'est pas la même chose de
faire le des confits demandant une
petite école rurale qui a trois ou
quatre classes que dans une école qui a
30 une trentaine de classes possiblement
de beaucoup plus nombreux enseignants
présents pour les collectivités locales
ça n'est pas la même chose ça ne sont
pas les mêmes contraintes
le cadre est indiscutable mais vraiment
cette concertation et d'applications ce
cas vous ont amené à faire un travail
tout en finesse avec les différents mais
différents acteurs dans les yvelines
plus précisément ce sont neuf cent dix
huit des neuf cent soixante cinq écoles
du territoire qui effectueront leur
entrée 17 semaines ou dans les prochains
jours ce qui représente 210 cette
commune yvelinoise un travail est mené
en ce moment avec les 20 autres qui ne
sont pas dans une démarche de
réouverture antoine destrés le directeur
académique des yvelines
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
sur les 20 vous en avez 16 qui ont deux
ou trois classes donc là on touche bien
aux difficultés spécifiques de la
ruralité avec un c'est souvent une
question de personnel qui n'est pas
selon le maire compétent pour le respect
strict du protocole sanitaire et donc
une seule commune d'importance donc maps
aviv qui elle n'a pas souhaité
renouveler ses écoles donc c'est surtout
en milieu
ce qui m'amène à dire une réflexion est
engagée avec le préfet avec le conseil
départemental avec les associations des
maires avec lesquels j'étais ce matin
pour voir si on ne pouvait pas venir en
aide
en appui à ces communes à ses 19
communes
donc voilà c'est la photographie du
moment mais c'est une photographie qui
pourra évoluer
une rentrée qui s'effectue de manière
très progressive et avec des
dispositions spécifiques à chaque
commune coup d'oeil au calendrier de
cette réouverture à saint quentin en
yvelines à partir de demain mardi 12 mai
les élèves notamment de magny les
hameaux trappe ou encore voisins le
bretonneux reprendront progressivement
le chemin des bancs scolaires pour l
encours la verrière ou encore les
clayes-sous-bois ce sera dès le jeudi 14
mai et à coignières et montigny le
bretonneux on a choisi la semaine
suivante pour la rentrée en ce qui
concerne guyancourt vous l'avez sûrement
vu sur l'animation précédentes la
rentrée pour les 25 écoles de la commune
c'est à partir de demain mardi près d'un
tiers des élèves sont attendus
réorganisation adaptation à des
enseignements aux règles sanitaires les
enseignants préparent leur classe à la
veille de cette reprise l'exemple dans
cette école deux aiguilles en course et
l'école francine fromont et cet exemple
il est adressé par nicolas landry et
mathilde demi côté tableau et essayer de
faire d un art de un arc de cercle ou
deux arc de cercle pour que tout va bien
espacées l'heure est à la préparation de
la rentrée des classes du 12 mai 2020 à
l'école maternelle francine fromont 20
enfants seront accueillis sur la
centaine d'inscrits dans cette classe de
petite section de maternelle quatre
élèves seront présents demain
chacun aura son espace avec deux tables
un tapis et son matériel
ils ont déjà des feutres un cahier de
dessin chacun ils ont six au pinceau de
cole écoles ils ont leila 3 puzzle pour
lui il ya les prix les lettres de son
prénom armée a reconstitué dans l'ordre
je vais lui il placer le modèle et je
vais installer des livres
de construction en plus des masques des
lingettes du gel hydroalcoolique ces
équipements seront fournis aux
enseignants et au personnel éducatif
marquage au sol indications sur les murs
de l'établissement
une nouvelle organisation pour respecter
les règles de distanciation sociale les
25 écoles de la ville ont mis en place
leur propre système
la décision de rouvrir les écoles
étaient assez évidente pour nous parce
que nous avons fait aussi le constat
durant ces huit semaines de confinement
maintenant qu'un certain nombre
d'enfants avaient impérativement besoin
de revenir à l'école alors on a des
arrivées échelonnées le matin par
exemple sur deux créneaux
8h20 à 8h30 8h35 8h45
même chose pour les sorties parce que
c'est surtout sur ces temps là aussi
qu'il faut faire attention qu'il n'est
pas de regroupement à l'entrée des
écoles le temps périscolaire sera aussi
assurée par la commune les accueils de
loisirs seront ouverts le mercredi un
accueil destinés aux enfants scolarisés
sur la ville de réouverture pour autant
des collèges comme pour les parcs et
jardins le département des yvelines
étant classé rouge sur la carte du
déconfinement est les yvelines où 448
personnes sont décédées dans les
hôpitaux des suites du coc vide 19,4 de
plus depuis les dernières données que
nous vous donnions jeudi soir le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation lui
continue de baisser
736 passion était hospitalisée dans le
département hier 68 en réanimation
et puis à 1580 le nombre de personnes
guéries du coronavirus dans le
département hormis les victimes
yvelinoise du coc vite 19 on a appris ce
dimanche la disparition de jean marc
fresnel 71 ans adjoint au maire de
versailles en charge des sports et des
ressources humaines depuis 2008
hospitalisé depuis plusieurs jours l'élu
est décédé à l'hôpital de rouen où il
avait été transféré et placé en
réanimation et jean-marc fresnel que
nous avions interrogé est reçu à de
nombreuses reprises sur le plateau de tv
78 très engagé comme conseiller
municipal mais aussi à l'organisation de
la célèbre course pédestre du paris
versailles il en était le président
depuis 1989 l'yvelinois travailler aussi
à l'accueil des jeux olympiques 2024 de
paris dont
versailles et ville haute de plusieurs
épreuves un homme apprécié de tous
un ami se souvient le maire de
versailles françois de mazières très ému
après cette disparition écouter et
frapper chez jean marc boueilh c'était
un homme extrêmement droit est
extrêmement attentif aux autres
au fond c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui
avait le sens du service public très
profondément et ramos le manque d'emploi
qui peut être un peu galvaudé mais lui
non c'était et s'était profondément lui
il avait commencé très tôt dans les
conseils de quartier aux années 80 il
avait été pendant trésorier d'abord de
du paris versailles puis président
depuis presque trente ans puisque plus
de trente ans mais quelques mois puisque
l'entente et puis moi si vous voulez je
lui avais connu jean marc passe quand
j'ai créé deux mois molière c'était très
vite devenu un pilier du mois parce que
c'était quelqu'un d'extrêmement curieux
et donc on le connaissait comme sportif
ancien pratiquant l'athlétisme à haut
niveau quand il était jeune mais mais sa
curiosité aller dans tous les domaines
et il a aimé beaucoup la vie culturelle
il aimait énormément voyagé avec son
épouse
donc voila c'était c'était vraiment une
belle personne comme on aime rencontrer
dans la vie
en signe d'hommage françois de mazières
a indiqué qu'il proposera au prochain
conseil municipal de donner le nom de
jean-marc fresnel au centre sportif de
porchefontaine un recueil digital a été
également ouvert pour que ceux qui le
souhaitent puissent y laisser un message
ou un souvenir
les cours à l'université ne reprendront
pas avant septembre mais certains
étudiants n'ont pas pu rentrer chez eux
pour autant pour celles et ceux qui
rencontrent des difficultés financières
l'épicerie sociale et solidaire de l'ue
vs qu l'agora et organisent des
distributions de paniers garnis chez le
reportage d'aurélie ans
pour cette deuxième distribution
solidaire plus de 200 paniers sont
préparés dans ce local à l'intérieur de
la nourriture et des produits d'hygiène
pour tenir un peu plus d'une semaine
une initiative de l'agora et l'épicerie
sociale et solidaire de l'ue vs q si
l'étudiant prend tout ce qui est proposé
il y a donc des légumes de producteurs
locaux
il ya des pâtes du riz une fois sable de
pulpe de tomate une bouteille de jus de
fruits de briques de lait du papier
toilette de des produits d'hygiène
féminine également de la compote des
pommes et pour le petit déjeuner soit
des céréales soit de la brioche
ce jour là les paniers sont répartis sur
plusieurs sites de distribution vélizy
versailles ou encore guyancourt ils sont
destinés en priorité aux étudiants en
situation de précarité financière et aux
étudiants santé mobilisés dans la crise
sanitaire
on c'est une situation qu'on connaît
tout au long de l'année et qui déjà
assez difficile à vivre pour ces
étudiants là mais qui est vraiment très
accentués et difficile à vivre et des
étudiants qui nous disent qu'ils se
nourrissent une fois par jour pour
éviter de gaspiller et pour pouvoir
tenir sur la durée une fois par jour
c'est quand même une idée sachant qu'en
général une fois par jour c'est par un
bon repas
c'est une fois par jour une assiette de
pâtes l'association a reçu une enveloppe
de 5000 euros pour confectionner ses
paniers d'une valeur de 18 euros
ça soulage un peu et ça facilite les
fins de mois surtout mes parents
pouvait jusqu'à maintenant assumer les
frais course et compagnie sauf que là
avec le co vide chômage technique et
compagnie c'est pas compris les
distributions de ces paniers garnis se
poursuivront pendant tout le mois de mai
pour s'inscrire rendez vous sur la page
facebook de l'association agora
et puis pour refermer cette première
édition spéciale déconfinement sachez
que certaines activités sont de nouveau
autorisés depuis aujourd'hui et des
disciplines sportives individuelles
comme le cyclisme le tennis ou encore le
boeuf pour les fans des greens des deux
sites notamment à saint quentin en
yvelines rouvrent leurs portes
le golf national et le blue green de
l'île de loisirs avec ben et
distanciation sociales sont bien sûr de
rigueur au golf national situé à
guyancourt pas de poubelles sur le
parcours à deux chariots pendant deux
mois elle les pratiquants doivent venir
avec la totalité de leurs équipements
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité
l'occasion de vous souhaiter à tous un
très bon déconfinement avec prudence
bien sûr et en suivant les
recommandations sanitaires très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]